you know that's what opposite so there's
no it's not opposite that so we worship
Allah upon Fe Love and Hope and fear so
we fear his
punishments and we hope that he will
enter us paradise and we love him you
understand so there's no contradiction
between the two so like I said I said
why we fear God you fear God if you fall
into to not disobey him
so cuz remember this life full ofation
so how can you help yourself to stay
away from the evil things by remember
God's Almighty is a powerful being it
can destroy any time so that that that
the attribute of powerful of Might what
does it point in your heart fear and
glorification but this fear is a
praiseworthy fear it's not blame worthy
fear and you know Allah mentioned the
Quran you know show you the power of the
way we feel God is different than
anything else
anything that you fear you run away from
correct except God when you fear God you
run Allah see is that clear
alhamdulillah that's what Allah in the
Quran flee to your Allah Allah because
there's no security and safety except
when you return to your creator the one
who the almighty the creator of
everything another question I wanted to
ask was uh the Islamic perspective on
Evolution cuz obviously just talking
about right now cuz like in University
they show you the physical proof on how
like come from apes and the DNA and just
the similarities but what's the Islamic
perspective on that firstly islamically
we reject it completely and there is not
living proof for ad Evolution cuz let as
you study go University let me ask you
what is scientific
method um it's research methods so it's
methods that have been um practiced upon
and reearch
for many years no no for in order for us
in order for us to say something
scientifically proven he has to go
through method which is collection of
data yeah through observation yeah and
then experimentation not just something
it has to be reputable understand for
example if the bot turn something for
example I have to keep repeating see the
which is can be proven it's not just
chance or something like that you
understand so when you look and then you
come to conclusion when you try to put a
scientific method on that Evolution it
fail so badly that's why Richard Dawkins
you know Richard Dawkins recogn yeah
Richard dkin one of the milit atheist
British one you know he's Pro Dar
Evolution he's a prop proper
evolutionist yeah he said when they
cored him about how can we not see
living example for that Evolution cuz
what they teaching in a school they not
teaching you the proof they they teach
you the explanation of what they believe
is a proof
let me make something clear for you
imagine I'm digging imagine I go
somewhere in Africa India or here I'm
digging yeah then I found a shoulder of
a dog yeah but I just found shoulder I
didn't I'm not sure if it's a dog or not
just shoulder yeah then I keep digging
then I found the forearm or say the leg
of sheep but I don't know if it's sheep
or not it's been I'm discovering
everything half not not completely if I
already believe in that Evolution have
all the PRI belief what I'm going to do
whatever Discovery I'm going to find I'm
going to I'm try to explain according to
my prior belief that's why there is no
when they say fossil fossils does not
prove their own Evolution he's not
showing me one species evolve into
completely different species I'm just
taking the word of a scientist his
explanation of quot unquote proofs is
that clear yeah but that's um there
another way they check for evolution is
they look at the change on DNA over time
so they can see how like the DNA in like
a monkey or any sort of animal and then
how that changes that how there's so
many similarities but there's slight
differences which which can cause a new
species to occur that would okay sh
having same DNA doesn't not mean
Evolution what indicate okay you see
again this is not proof this explanation
I can say okay having same DNA Pro we
came from same Creator who create Us in
the same way you see that's not proof so
what I'm doing I looked at something cuz
I've already have a prior belief I'm
going to explain according to my belief
now you have that Evolution he's going
to say because we have the same DNA
therefore we prove Evolution for example
if you see a bike then you see a
motorbike then you see a scooter then
you see what they call it I say a truck
you to say you know what therefore truck
evolv from scooter so with scooter bike
no why we going to say the one who
created these items is the same person
so again that is not a proof brother
that's explanation of qut and quot
approve one more thing about evolution
is you know the common code the flu yeah
so they have V vaccinations but it's
every year right every year they offer
vaccinations I don't take vaccination
I'm guess this brother yeah so they
offer a vaccination for the flu but the
reason why they do it every year is
because every year the flu virus changes
like it evolves it adapts it has a
mutation so it changes that's why have
to regularly give it what about again so
every year they give what every year
they give a new vaccination because they
have to because the virus changes do we
believe that there proof there's
scientific data proof everything you can
see how the virus changes if you get a
virus they put it on like a little plate
and they change the conditions the virus
will change so to adapt to the new like
environment yeah that's that's by
observation and exper no but again again
cuz me I'm not really into this virus
stuff I have different aspects from this
virus stuff to be honest like a mutation
of virus but for the sake of arguments
that virus did it tend to complet
different species no it's slight change
I mean like what is the point of that
that's we have that's not that Evolution
that
Evolution when one species evolve to
completely different species and like I
said Richard dokan is one of the pro
Evol the evolution he said that we
cannot prove that like again this
explanation this what again we have
brother yeah you know when the scientist
go to the lab they have a prayer
Bel I mean not all the time all of them
there's no exception do you know there
there is a
physicist called
Pizza um Let me give Peter Artic uh he's
a British scientist he's he's a
wellknown famous British scientist
physic
yeah he said to him imagine the Stars
the start the star they start writing on
in the sky Peter believe in me I'm God
would you believe he said no I will
think is a
magic that guy who a scientist when he's
going to go to the lab he already has a
belief so whatever he's going to
discover that indicate that is God what
he's going to do he's going to explain
it in a way to go according to his prior
belief don't none of them go I'm not
sure if you watch the the the the
document called The Expelled ones The
Expelled ones this documentary was done
by a Jewish
the the journalist he went to America to
best Universe in America he found when
the scientists tried to prove God's
existence they will be removed from the
universities so what I'm saying to you
don't believe what they say again now
what we say to you look rationally
rationally let rationally how many years
human beings existed
like a couple thousand so EV if you
accept evolution evolution is coming
from everything random okay Everything
Is Random now if you accept that how on
the earth we can see everything is been
designed for example I never heard in my
life Maybe person no that's no this is
the reality that's how you expose this
Dar evolutionist yeah how come we never
seen a woman giving a birth to an animal
animal giving a birth to human because
why you have to understand brother what
is random random Anything Can Happen are
you with me don't tell me it's imagine
now imagine I got a stick and there's 20
of you I come and keep heating you keep
heating you and you every time ask me
say why you keep heating him I say it's
random that's not random that's why they
say they say something been repeated
intentionally remove
Randomness you with me that shows there
is I'm intending it there is a will
behind it and so on so this creation the
Way's been created clearly any human
being with a sound reasoning will not
accept this nonsense that will Evolution
rather I will show you something think
one of the scientist a brother put it up
in WhatsApp group yeah look what he said
he said why we accept that Evolution
yeah let me show you this
yeah uh
okay the theory of evolution is
universally accepted not because it can
be proven true but because the only
authenti is special creation by God
which is clearly incredible this is
nature you know nature one of the well
known no because can be proven why
because is one of the tool that has been
used to reject God's
existence sense I can go on on there's
many proof after I'll give you because
what you have to understand brother yeah
you know that when your Evolution like I
said there's many ways of disproving it
but what in universities and colle and
schools the way they teach it as if as a
fact all right another question just the
last question no problem it's just on
the whole idea of predestination and
Free Will okay so obviously God has
given us free will that's right and we
understand that but what's the point of
free will if everything is predetermined
anyways like at the end of the day you
know way it's already written where
you're going to go uh Heaven hell um but
you're still given free will to somehow
sway to like your decisions your choices
when at the end of the day it doesn't
matter because it's already written for
you so I don't see how they work
together I mean the the Free Will
According to Islamic teaching there's no
negation between Free Will and God
knowing what you're going to you
understand Allah knowing when you're
going to but do you know where you're
going to so in order for you to know
where you're going to we have to do
obviously like do good deeds deeds and
so and so and I show you there is a free
will imagine I come to you now you know
and I take you pH and I said don't blame
me there not free have been forced to
would you accept that from me no okay
that's not right see because that's why
that's why one our musim schols when one
the Christians start to use that when a
Christian TR say why God's going to
blame me for me born Christian when he
created as a Christian you understand
but so there's no free will no that's
why in Islam to show you there is a free
will and Allah will not judge you if
something is out of your control did you
know islamically speaking if you are
sleeping and you start insulting Allah
Allah will to hold you accountable why
cuz one of the faculties is not there
you sleeping you understand now if
you've been forced to to do something
evil you've been forced to Allah will
not hold you accountable now imagine
your you you you try to do something and
you stap your mother Allah will not hold
you accountable even though slapping
your mother is is a major sin however
why Allah is not holding if there's no
free will Allah should hold you
accountable for everything that you're
going to do cuz there not free will to
begin with the fact that in Islam Allah
differentiate between the actions that
which clearly you have no Free Will and
there's action which you have free will
now if you go to police station imagine
I get arrested and they take me to court
and I said to the judge don't blame me
I've been forced to would the would the
judge take me serious no no because I
said imagine I robed people and I judge
don't blame me I just I been forc to you
see that's why reality show us that we
have free will and in Islam like for
example even Islam goes beyond that look
even if you have you have free will now
imagine now I I drink alcohol I'm Muslim
I drink Al but I didn't know I just
became Muslim I didn't know that alcohol
is Haram no one forced me I have my
faculties of reasoning however Allah
will not hold you accountable why
because of ignorance to show you Allah
is just that's why Allah mention the
Quran Allah will never punish anyone
until the proof been established upon
them that's why if someone dies and he
never heard about Islam on the day of
Resurrection Allah will not judge him
straight away rather Allah will test him
CU Allah is the most just so Allah
knowing something decreeing something
doesn't not negate that we have free
make sense what about the whole
predestination then so it's like yeah
cuz if it's already written where you're
going to end up yeah then
what's the point of testing us if like I
guess you cuz so Allah has written
everything yes but do you know what is
going to happen to you no I don't you
don't know so Allah said I on the day of
judgment
Allah if imag Allah create us and put us
straight in the Hellfire what are we
going to say I can't do nothing yeah you
see that's it's not just yeah but so now
now when Allah put you in this earth
that's what Allah gave judgments some
this this believers they will say oh
Allah when never did it Allah will make
their limbs to speak to witness to
testify and guess them so this and guess
to you see so Allah knows but we don't
know that's why now for example Allah
knows that if I'm going to be rich or
not
yes you know but do I know I don't know
so is it is it logical for me to sit
down I said you know imagine you tell me
go make money I Allah already decreed
for me I'm not going to have money you
say you're not even working go take the
means then you come to know you
understand so they take the means for us
to know what Allah decreed for us so
Allah written it down Allah de
everything does not negate our Free Will
likewise that Allah put us here to
testify against our own s make sense
yeah that makesense is it clear yeah
that's that's alhamdulillah so you want
to become Muslim um I need to be more
like researching until when I feel it I
I know okay let me ask you something
yeah so you believe in God yeah you
believe that we we are here for a
purpose okay so logically speaking the
one who should know about our purpose is
our creator all right and
now I I give I always give example
imagine in the
house imagine tonight you go to sleep
and you wake up and there's a fire
everywhere there's a fire everywhere and
you tried to save yourself but you
couldn't you gave up I came and I saved
your life what would you say to me at
least thank you would you remember me
all the time yeah I save your life bro
so why we are not grateful and remember
who give us a life for free you see when
I said to you if I saved your life
you're going to say to me you know what
let me think let me do deep research
what my Sho size you're not going to cuz
why you are working with the foundation
you don't have to know my shoe size or
how many children I have to appreciate
what I have did for you this is just a
simple example your own existence our
own existence is by the virtue of Allah
by our creator you understand so
logically is well now imagine you want
to buy a gift for your mother would you
buy a gift that you love or your mother
love something that she loves she loves
likewise if you want to worship and you
want to be grateful to Creator we should
worship him the way he loves that's why
brother look why I say to you look when
you look at Islam look you know you know
we're talking about scientists and all
of that yeah you know Islam came to
preserve five things that's I'm going to
show you why Islam is very special why
this religion must be from the creator
of everything
Islam came to preserve five things Islam
came to preserve
religion you with me what does it mean
religion Islam came to preserve the
Oneness of Allah that's why Islam
paganism politicism is
forbidden that's why Oneness of God we
allow we're not allowed to pray to
Prophet Muhammad we're not we're not
allowed to pray to no one that's one
firstly secondly Islam came to preserve
intellect yeah that's why alcohol and
drugs
forbidden thirdly Islam came to preserve
wealth the wealth yeah that's why
interest and gambling is forbidden
fourthly Islam came to preserve marriage
life that's why fornication adultery is
forbidden fifthly Islam came to preserve
lives that's why killing people
unjustice forbidden these five things
that Islam came to protect not just
protect it there's a barriers there's
punishment for breaking them yeah this
when we do not protect them and and
preserve them what happened to our
society these five six have mentioned of
the four things called destroy our
societies let me ask you alcohol is it
good for us or bad for us it's bad for
us collectively and individually okay
drugs is it bad for us bad collectively
interest it's better interest make the
rich richer and the poor poorer it's
better for us individually and
collectively gambling same thing yeah uh
fornication adultery is same thing
causing destruction abortions babies
dying over over a million of babies
dying yearly you know so these five
things in our society is not just we
allow it it's been propagated and
glamorized even though it destroy us
individually collectively however there
is some people are benefiting from
it are making money from it there is no
doubt about that who are they majority
of time those who are in power that's
why majority of times those who are very
hostile to Islam are those who are in
charge or in power why even though Islam
is good for them and for their society
you know why because they look at Islam
as a threat for their
business see what I'm saying so the
question you ask yourself how man that
ex and all of these evils gambling uh
fornication adultery all of these evils
it goes back to the first one which is
when you turn away from God when you
have no guideline from the Creator you
start following your desires you wake up
you say I'm a woman you wake up and say
I'm not a man I'm not a woman I'm an
animal why because I have no guideline
and Allah mentioned in the Quran if the
truth follow people desires the heavens
and the Earth will be corrupted and we
can see that right now in the so-call
Civilized countries so people you know
we are bleeding from within you know so
how man that exist 1,400 years ago he
was able to come with a perfect way of
life yet we have the scientists
professors politicians Who start in the
best universities around the world they
cannot resolve the problems that we are
going through but we have a man who
couldn't read and write he's coming with
this perfect way of life cuz that man
clearly mentioned he a messenger of the
Creator you know the Quran there's a
verse in the Quran name j v Vish sorry
mix the other guy I was speaking to what
say to Vish there is verse in the Quran
is so powerful Allah mentioned the Quran
it is Allah who sent his Prophet with
truth religion with Islam in order for
Islam to Prevail the other religions
even if this Believers dislike it now in
the Western World you know in Australia
by itself every day there's 50 articles
in newspaper speaking about Islam in a
negative way just Australia imagine put
that on a big scale around the world yet
the fastest growing religion on the in
the West World Islam who's doing the job
we are weak the Muslims the Muslim
countries are weak CU Allah mentioned
that in the Quran 1,400 years ago that
prophecy when to Islam brother is a
perfect way of life connect you to
Creator make you understand the reality
of this life you understand you worship
there's only one Creator the creator of
everything he should be worshiped alone
no look Allah how Allah described
himself say Allah is the only one Allah
is a master
self-sufficient he's not in need of no
one everyone's in need of
him there's nothing like onto him that's
the Creator how describe himself we to
Prophet Muhammad let me show you why
Prophet Muhammad it's impossible that he
was a liar yeah let me show you some
instance yeah Prophet Muhammad you want
to sit down you sure yeah Prophet
Muhammad wasam let me give you water got
water you got water yeah okay Prophet
Muhammad wasam once his his son passed
away Ibrahim yeah when his son Ibrahim
passed away the same day what happened
Eclipse yes so what His companion said
said the reason his son passed away or
the reason there is Eclipse because his
son passed away remember a liar will try
to utilize any opportunity to benit
benefit himself to back up his claim
yeah to be a Propet so what he did he
said no it's not related it's not
related what he did he said go and pray
to the Creator to Allah Im so compare
this with Christoper Columbus
Christopher Columbus when he went to
America and when eclipse happened they
didn't know why you know what he said he
said the god of the Bible is not happy
with you so you have to give you items
so look this evil Man how he utilized
the ignorance to manipulate them look
look at the on the other side prophet of
Allah Muhammad how he never misu Mis
utilize or manipulate the people because
the ignorance that's one I give you
another one during his lifetime his
friend was married to a woman
that woman she didn't like him anymore
she said I don't want to stay with you
leave me alone he loved her so much he
used to follow her in the road in the
streets Prophet Muhammad said are you
not amazed how much he loves her and how
much you hat him so Prophet Muhammad
Alat went to her he said listen why
don't you go back to him remember that
his friend she said oh messenger of
Allah is it a commandment from Allah he
told you to have to go back to him or is
it just you you want to mediate again if
it was
imagine you are my friend and I'm a liar
because the biggest liar someone who CLA
who claim to prophet of God and we are
friends we are buddies why I'm going to
do I'm going to manipulate the woman to
believe you understand but what he said
to her he said no it's not from God I'm
just trying to help if you want to go
back go back that is not Char
characteristics of Allah I can give you
many examples for once he was he was
traveling with his friends remember his
companions they raise him he's a
messenger of Allah no doubt yeah so he
he was in the hole
they were taking turns they will travel
long distance then he said to Ali his
comp his cousin he said as you turn now
he said no messenger of Allah you don't
worry he said no you're not stronger
than me and you're not a need of reward
more than me I need of reward so I let
you take the house as well that is not a
nature of a liar someone who even when
he come to his life you know when he be
when Allah Aid him you know this verse
in the Quran Allah mention the Quran the
meaning of the verse yeah oh Muhammad
you will never die and you will never be
killed until you convey the
message let us understand this verse
here it's so powerful when this verse
was revealed to Prophet Muhammad
wasallam that Allah is going to protect
you until you convey the message mean
you you never die and you'll never be
killed until you convey the whole
message yeah when this verse was
revealed to him Prophet Muhammad was not
hiding in his house or behind the
Fortress he was involved in the battles
in a places when there's more likely
that you'll be killed he was poisoned
they put Magic on him he never he was
never k no one killed him until he
conveyed the message and he stood and he
saw the people his companions AB lead
the prayer and he smile that is not from
someone who was a false god that's why
Islam we you see people accepting Islam
because it go our sound reasoning
likewise there's tangible proofs why
Islam is a truth and one day we're going
to die just today I give us talk about
death that's what Allah in the Quran
always remind us with death you have to
understand bro how many people left the
houses they never come back how many
people want sleep they never wake up
imagine you go to sleep tonight while
you sleeping someone come and raise you
and pick you
up while you don't know you not even up
you still you're on a deep sleep and
they put you in a cave in a mountain in
India or something the last thing you
remember you remember that you w sleep
in your room now you wake up you are in
a cave how you going to be like shocks
confused probably you going probably
lose it yeah so it's death you're going
to be walking maybe or go sleep and
Allah sour the angels will come and take
your so are we prepared for that day why
we say to you look yes it's good to read
more and more but I say the foundation
is clear and it makes sense become a
Muslim you understand because like I
said when you go to GP I'll give you
example when you go to GP you don't know
your GP Sho size you don't know true you
don't know you know what I'm saying but
that's good if you don't know but you
know what is the foundation that he's an
expert that's what you're working with
so when you to Islam the foundation is
clear I can go on about prophecies about
interest Prophet Muhammad said your
interest will become widespread even if
you're not if you even if you are not
involved directly will affect you
indirectly Now by default if you open a
bank account you are involing interest
how man that existed 1,400 years ago was
able to know that you understand you
have to understand bro if it makes sense
is it clear to you then learning more
and more you can do it after but it's
better off you become Muslim you leave
may Allah forbid if you die you die with
SH you understand bro does it make sense
yeah Mak sense bro that's what I'm
saying why you deleting it you know
learning learning brother you know my is
a raver by the way I have my brother
here is a Reaver too when you want to
become a Muslim prophet muham mm said
Satan will put many barriers from you my
parents my families this that but
remember all those barriers may Allah
forbid if you die will not be valid FR
of your creator yes take care of your
parents no doubt about that but there's
priorities God created you you you
breathing in out the oxygen for free and
yet you don't want to submit to
him well we should be feel ashamed of
ourselves for not submit to our Creator
when we get all these blessings from him
may Allah forbid imagine you get disease
or I get disease if you go to hospital
and if you need the oxygen you they will
charge you for it you creat is giving
you to for free for what just worship
him alone don't worship no one beside
him no trees no Prophet Muhammad no any
creature except
himself that's why I invite you become
musah step by step learn if it makes
sense you believe is the
truth what is it
I bear witness there's no one worthy of
worship except Allah I should worship my
Creator I should be grateful to him
Muhammad the messenger Allah according
to his messenger
Muhammad look this all this these
transgressions and oppression that is
been happening to the Muslims yet the
fast growing religion on the face of the
earth is
Islam you understand bro so better bro
you know this submitting to your creator
yeah I know it's like I'll just think
about what happen today and then soon in
I don't want to put pressure on you but
alhamd this is my advice to you I will
give you something to read inah uh we
have this Quran it's very
good what is your background like what
is it sik Hindu uh Hindu Hinduism yeah
it's like I've got family that are
Muslim so my uncle's Muslim he's a reer
become Muslim
man man only get the reward brother you
have your
uncle alhamdulillah I mean what I've
explained to you what we say to you look
you know when God create us yeah he
create us with the
tools sound reasoning natural
inclination and when he send down the
Revelation that Revelation Clicks in
with our
tools that's why majority of people
accept Islam straight away why because
he's thinking that's what I already
believe it's going in line with my
natural inclination you understand
that's why that's the beauty of Islam
because the one who created you is the
same one who sent down that Revelation
you have an uncle bro you should be more
you know don't no like okay imagine you
die today do you think that excuse would
be valid from the
Creator you have to fear Allah you know
well lie is not a joke if you know that
brother you know there was a guy that I
used to know he was 16 years old he was
from Bush I don't know if you heard
about it his friends told him let's go
to
Victoria when he went to Victoria got
stub and he died I said to the brothers
if you went to that brother who
died uh in Victoria if you told him
before he left bro maybe you'll die
today he would say yeah yeah yeah but he
will not think he's going to die today
yeah you see what I'm saying anything
can happen bro I will say to you if you
know the excuse that you are utilizing
now for not taking shahada is not valid
for you front of your creator Li I don't
know man you brother yeah alhamdulillah
you from India Bangladesh Bangladesh
yeah brother I at reward that's why you
know that's why I'm motivating you
brother bro you said it by yourself you
in front of us that your excuse is not
valid in front of your creator that's
what Allah
said are we going to make equal the
Believers with disbelievers how can you
judge grow your own existence by his
virtue you understand when I saved you
you didn't say something let me think
about
it you didn't say
that
brother you said you were Rel
brother
understand I just need to give
everything today no problem no problem
brother I don't want to put pressure
like too much you brother but uh if you
have any other questions do you have any
questions not right now in you East L
you said where in East
like okay we every Friday
okay I take I take
the you to come back here with me inah
so you can come Friday take my number
yeah yeah do you have my number yeah
take my number if you need then you can
just contact me yeah this Quran is very
good even the end of it look it speaks
about you know
the Jesus and what is the
uh Declaration of
Faith yeah it's very
good uh yeah so
so
uh okay there phone number
yeah you have an iPhone as well
yeah yeah iPhone I have iPhones
yeah uh yeah so what I'm going to do you
know about talk about the
evolution WhatsApp me and I'll send you
links to and you can
read
brother doesn't make sense yeah yeah I
mean that is the big the biggest silly
thing but I will say to you that one
evolution is the
biggest uh what they call it
hallucination but because the way it's
being taught in universities and the
schools and the colleges some people get
Twisted by it but when you go study it
and investigate it you can see there's
differ between what is a actual proof
and explanation of that you understand
for example imagine I don't believe a
camera was made by human
beings so if I see any indication to
indicate the camera was made by human
being well I'm going to try to try to
explain it away to go in line with my
belief even some Muslims do that you
know have you heard that scientifically
proven in the Quran yeah yeah yeah I've
seen all that stuff there this stuff
some of it a lot I believe majority of
it it's not true it's fake I agree yeah
100% like for example that the Universe
came with a big bang I don't believe
that is in the Quran that's not true so
again cuz they some scientist Muslims
what they do the same thing they see
something they will try to explain
according to their beliefs we as a
Muslim aldah we can stand front of
camera say yes they're wrong you
understand brother nice to meet you
inshah hopefully I see you next time